with the latin [ __ ] that's going on i
saw you were just um
a part of that photo a lot of the la
like mexican guys who are in town cng
and all those guys but um you know
there's a whole nother movement going on
there that's
[ __ ] amazing out of la yeah um just
in general
um but what what it like like what do
you think
when it comes to like because i always
said like when i was growing up like
when i thought i'm from phoenix so mc
magic was like god right oh yeah
and i was like you know working at car
shows and [ __ ] but like the mexican rap
that was really popular was the chicano
rap yeah and to me
i mean little roguelike classics yeah
emcee magic got classics but i always
felt like
there was a um it did you had to be
it was almost like made specifically for
for for
for the people who got that yeah it
wasn't very inclusive to
random i feel like like a lot of the new
latin mcs that are doing their thing
like they make dope [ __ ]
and they happen to be mexican that's
really the key you know what i mean
because
a lot of like me growing up like i had
like a period of time where i did like
the chicano wrap stuff i was into mc
magics and
and all that but then i just kind of
grew out of it because i wasn't like a
gangbanger
right i didn't relate too much the
things i like the music you know
but like it's almost like it's in such
like a
cult-like fan base that you couldn't
really get out of that box and they
could have a million views like [ __ ]
high-power records
high power records all that [ __ ] them
[ __ ] i better go they'd have them boots
at the [ __ ] car shows their shits
would be booming
and then they have random albums like
busy bone and [ __ ] yeah they were they
were doing it on the independent tip you
could buy them at like warehouse you
selling [ __ ] like
but yeah i think that like that's
something that like it's like now
there's artists where it's like you
could be a fan of this guy and be
you know whoever you don't have to be a
mexican to like you know like the music
is just good you know
that's yeah that's the whole goal and
that's what i see everybody doing like
we had like that meeting yesterday and
it was dope
because yeah like they're just dope
artists who happen to be mexican that
some of them probably don't even speak
spanish like they don't incorporate
spanish into their lyrics or anything
like that it's just like
they grew up in la they're mexican they
have you know homies that are black
white chinese everything you know and
they just they rap like you know and
they're good what was give us the inside
of the meeting yesterday because i saw a
few people post it
yeah it was it was pretty dope um
basically we pulled up to uh
abner mars you know i'm reminiscent of
fighter yeah he has a spot in like bell
gardens
a restaurant and so uh we all just
pulled up and
um basically like they're just planning
i mean like
the cool thing is that everybody knows
each other but it was like still like a
mixer because you're still meeting
people face to face and feeling people's
energy and stuff like that
but like they're planning on doing like
a cypher
fire you know what i mean like something
like that to where everybody gets on a
song
and then possibly you know go on like a
tour